deuxième sujet si vous le verrez bien
patrick balkany en quatre ans de prison
10 ans d'inéligibilité
l'incarcération immédiate le maire de
levallois perret et son épouse condamnée
elle à trois ans mais dispensée pour des
raisons de santé de la case prison ont
été jugés aujourd'hui par le tribunal
correctionnel de paris pour fraude
fiscale
je rappelle que sept ans avaient été
requis il encourait je crois même 10 on
est trop perrier pardon il ya deux
volets dans la sphère et à la volée
fraude fiscale de l'autre en chine
lancée dans le volet blanchiment
vivement il sera jugé au mois d'octobre
et cory que les quatre les secteurs
avaient été requis là il a été moins
d'années à ce qui avait été requis c'est
à dire quatre ans balkany
elle a été condamnée au delà des
réquisitions puisqu'ils avaient été
requis simplement deux ans elle a été
condamnée à trois ans pour le maire de
levallois patrick balkany c'est les
réquisitions qui ont été suivies par le
tribunal
un jour donne la parole mais j'aimerais
juste qu'on l'entende évidemment la
réaction de maître dupond-moretti à la
sortie du tribunal il ya quelques
quelques heures ce qui me choque le plus
c'est évidemment le mandat de dépôt qui
est une humiliation totalement inutile
et pour nous insupportable jamais
personne ne peut dire sérieusement que
monsieur balkany aurait tenté prendre la
fuite il a été présent à tous les actes
de la procédure
je pense qu'on s'est payé balkany
aujourd'hui nous allons bien sûr
interjeté appel et nous n'acceptons pas
que l'on se soit payée balkany ce que
nous attendons c'est que balkany soient
jugés et s'est singulièrement différent
m périat je me retourne vers vous à
nouveau le mandat de dépôt ce qu'est ce
qu'il dit vous paraît frappée du bon
sens on exagère un peu comme mandat de
dépôt oui vraiment le mandat de dépôt je
ne le comprends pas il est possible
juridiquement il ya aucun problème dès
qu'on prononce une peine supérieure à un
grand père et oui mais simplement le
code vous dis donc le mandat de dépôt
qu'est ce que c'est c'est vous allez en
prison
vous pouvez faire appel mais il ya une
exécution provisoire normalement l'appel
suspend les choses là c'est une forme de
mesure d'urgence où nous dit vous allez
en prison vous allait interjeter appel
peut-être mais vous restez en prison et
la loi dit que c'est possible
à titre de mesure de sûreté ça veut dire
quand même que il faut assurer
l'exécution de la peine
et donc il ya un risque de fuite
et s'il n'y a pas de risque de fuite le
mandat de dépôt n'a pas de sens
il n'a de sens que pour assurer
l'exécution de la peine sinon le
principe c'est que ont fait appel et que
l'appel est suspensif puisqu'on doit
respecter la présomption d'innocence et
que tant que la condamnation n'est pas
définitive
elle ne peut pas à s'exécuter il peut
même y avoir un pourvoi en cassation
et ça n'est qu'à l'issue de l'ensemble
de ces voies de recours qu'on peut en
tirer les conséquences et qu'on vous met
en prison le cas échéant là il ya une
sorte d'urgence qui est en réalité
totalement me semble-t-il
disproportionnée et incompréhensible je
ne dis pas que la peine dès 4 ans est
incompréhensible jeudi que le mandat de
dépôt est un composé qu'est ce qui va se
passer maintenant l'appel c'est dans
quelques jours donc il va te non non
l'appel c'est pas dans quelques jours
qu'est ce qui va se passer là il va
faire appel
oui mais là s'il ne l'a déjà fait et là
elle cour d'appel va être saisi de deux
choses elle va être saisie du fonds elle
va et butin qui sera jugée d'ici un an
18 mois que sais-je
et puis parallèlement elle va être saisi
d'une demande de mise en liberté puisque
évidemment patrick balkany parallèlement
à l'appel
puisqu'il est toujours présumé innocent
du fait de cet appel va contester ce
mandat de dépôt et va demander sa mise
en liberté et il sera libéré et bien sûr
qu'il soit ce sera dans quelques jours
non là on se met la cour d'appel a deux
mois à 2 moore examiner la demande de
limousis en liberté à compter du jour
elle est faite elle va être fait dans
les tout prochains jours bien évidemment
mais il va pas être libéré par exemple
je pense qu'au deuxième verdict qui le
18 octobre qui sera toujours détenus
parce que la cour d'appel n'aura pas
examiner cette demande de mise en
liberté dont elle a deux mois il va
rester deux mois des 1 donc on n'est pas
dans l'ordre du symbole il ya c'est un
procès politique
vous pensez souvent payés balkany pour
des raisons extra moi je me permets de
me plonger dans mes notes pour vous lire
un peu quand même la motivation du
mandat qui était quand même en
soulignant de l'indéniable enracinement
de monsieur balkany sur une longue
période dans une délinquance fortement
rémunératrice et de la circonstance qui
ne saurait être exclu que les intérêts
économiques de l'intéressé continuent de
diverger du sol national et c'est donc
les faits sont graves
allez faites sont à bannir non ça n'a
rien à voir avec bien sûr la grammaire
effet c'est la peine le mois d'avancé la
sûreté juste pour répondre sur le fait
qu'effectivement du fait de la gravité
des accusations portées contre lui il y
a sans doute eu peut-être je ne sais pas
je n'ignore une volonté de
un exemple et c'est pas impossible que
cela est justifié du fait de la
notoriété de l'accusé que ça avait pu
justifier cette volonté de marquer un
coup fort qui peut pas dire que parce
que quelqu'un ait connu qu'on va émettre
un mandat de dépôt pour faire un exemple
veut dire c'est extra c'est sûr est
d'ailleurs le substitut dont là encore
je me permets de citer le nom parce que
je ne le connais pas et je ne suis pas
les affaires judiciaires arnaud de la
guiche qui design faut pas se venger
mais restaurer l'ordre social je pense
que tous autour de la table nous sommes
d'accord sur ce point
ensuite il y aura sans doute des
justifications à venir sur ce sur sur ce
thème a été ronny valentin les hommes
politiques ne sont ils pas tenus d'être
un peu plus exemplaire que les autres
ce qui expliquerait que leur peine peut
être beaucoup plus de particuliers dans
une démocratie il me semble t-il tout le
monde doit juger de la même façon on a
un code de procédure pénale qui est là
justement pour assurer que la loi est
appliquée la même façon à tout le monde
et la manière la plus sereine dont le
problème en fait avec cette décision
pour que moi j'ai pas de commentaire à
faire sur le fond d'un dossier que je ne
connais pas et j'ai exercé en tant
qu'avocat suffisamment longtemps pour
pour savoir qu' il faut se méfier des
avis donnés comme ça sans reconnaître
exactement le détail des faits rond puis
je suis en tant que grande partie des
partisans de la démocratie
je tiens absolument à ce qu'on respecte
les décisions de justice le problème
c'est qu'une fois de plus dans cette
décision la justice finalement montre
qu'on ne peut pas lui faire confiance
et malheureusement ça arrive de plus en
plus en plus en plus le saint qui vous
qui vous fait dire un évidemment qu'elle
de confiance bien évidemment mais il y
en a tellement
regardez regardez avec jean luc
mélenchon a passionné commencé partie du
mur des comptes par exemple où le
syndicat de la magistrature ne s'est
même pas donné la peine de justifier de
dire où était né à mur d'écrans de notre
local syndical mais nous sommes
impartiaux nous tenons à notre
impartialité ne sont pas du tout
expliqué là-dessus mais il ya d'autres
cas évidemment ce qui s'est passé le
parquet national financiers les pompiers
de la fère clients une fois de plus je
parle pas du fond je parle du moment je
pars du timing
la célérité
par des fuites dans les médias accord
avec jean-luc mélenchon qui vont c'est
au hasard angie dupond-moretti il dit
autant plus aquila que ya pas très
longtemps de ça il défend des kayaks
pour le coup cayzac on peut se demander
pourquoi il ait mis si longtemps à juger
et pourquoi est ce que lui non pas de
mandat dépendrait d'emprisonnement parce
qu'il ya une peine de prison mais je
crois qu'avec les remises de peine
finalement il a jamais été en prison
et bien parce que la loi le permet alors
que ce qu'il a fait franchement été
scandaleux mais une fois de plus le
problème c'est que dans une démocratie
nous avons besoin de faire confiance à
la justice c'est très important et
qu'aujourd'hui il s'est passé tellement
de choses encore une fois avec une
génération identitaire moi je le déteste
generation-nt terre je n'ai rien
d'aucune affection pour génération
identitaire mais les peines qu'ils ont
reçue par rapport à d'autres types pour
les mêmes faits par d'autres types de
personnes c'est des peines qui sont
extrêmement sévères
pareil pour les gilet jaune il ya des
manières les conditions dans lesquelles
ont été jugés les jeunes montent ya une
politisation une pipolisation la justice
un lien de plus en plus évident entre la
justice et les médias est
malheureusement un lien aussi de plus en
plus évident entre la justice et les
politiques
et ça ça en verlan moi je ne mettrais
quand même pas tout ça dans le même sac
je pense que là il faut s'attarder sur
balkany la sphère balkany le jugement
qui a été prononcé comme vous l'avez
très bien dit qui est le premier de deux
jugements puisque le deuxième à
intervenir le 18 octobre
peut-être à ce moment-là sera-t-il
encore incarcérés ou peut-être quand
même on peut le penser
sera-t-il sortie de prison moi je pense
que patrick balkany pays
autre chose alors le côté exemple mise
en avant par dupont moretti c'est
certain mais c'est autre chose qu'il
paye c'est son comportement pendant le
procès moi j'ai pris 20 mai patrick
balkany peut-être par moments parce
qu'il s'est laissé emporter ce n'était
pas nécessairement prémédité mais il a
eu vis-à-vis du tribunal une forme de
très fortes désinvolture et aucun
remords c'est la grande différence avec
jérôme cahuzac j'ai aussi suivi le
procès jérôme cahuzac qui n'a pas
apporté de détail sur l'origine des
fonds en tout cas il n'a pas répondu aux
questions des magistrats sur un certain
nombre de points mais par contre il est
est repentant on peut
il a reconnu sa faute il est arrivé
devant le tribunal dans une position de
coupables qui reconnaît ses erreurs ce
n'était pas du tout le cas de patrick
balkany qui en plus a ajouté
là encore une fois peut-être parce que
c'est ça le tempérament balkany c'est
peut-être ça l'histoire balkany ces deux
là se lance là encore il y a eu chaud
j'ai pas employé le terrain c'est
pourquoi avec un bonnet d'âne sauf que
le mandat des fois c'est fait pour la
sûreté s'est passé pour que je pense
qu'il ya aussi avec je suis pas d'accord
avec vous sur aussi la sphère cahuzac on
ne peut pas comparer les deux dans la
mesure où jérôme cahuzac
bon il ya eu enrichissement personnel
sur la base de son travail d'un plan de
cheveux etc
chez monsieur balkany on est dans une
autre dimension
on est alors pas la main dans ce jeu
c'est mais là en l'occurrence on est
vraiment dans un autre dossier les deux
ne se compare pas en terme de gravité
peine et banda de dépôt et ça swingue à
qui l'on doit la série télé car m est ce
que c'est une première selon vous ce
mandat de dépôt dans une affaire de ce
type
je n'en ai pas elle vraiment le mandat
de dépôt à l'audience c'est une mesure
qui est con qu'on voit beaucoup à la
cour d'assises
parce que c'est quasiment automatique
quand on comparaît détenu ait compris
qu'on est condamné on vous prend
immédiatement et on vous emmène en
prison dans des affaires politiques ou
financières non à ma connaissance non
mais ce qui est intéressant est
peut-être revenir un peu sur la
chronologie des choses donc il ya ce
premier mandat de dépôt il en en cours
un second le 18 octobre parce que quand
bien même il serait libéré peut être
courant octobre
dans cette affaire là rien ne dit que
s'ils ont mis en mandat de dépôt sur des
réquisitions de quatre ans qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire sur des réquisitions
de sept ans dans l'aspect blanchiment au
mois d'octobre dont il peut très bien
sortir et y retourner le 18 oct auquel
cas il refera appel et il va ressortir
en attendant cette fois ci que la cour
d'appel se prononce sur le tout pour
illustrer ce que vous dites il vient de
déposer une demande de remise en liberté
la question suivante et va-t-il pouvoir
faire campagne avec bracelet
électronique
alors attention il est plein de grâce
l'électronique ainsi les libérer il élit
le bracelet électronique c'est une
modalité d'exécution d'une peine là il
n'est pas en exécution
il est toujours présumé innocent puisque
c'est un appel aussi les libérer il est
libéré sèchement le après le par exemple
cahuzac et sous bracelet parce que sa
peine et définitive ils l'exécutent sous
la forme d'un bracelet
donc c'est un tout petit peu différent
s'il sort il sort et il n'est même pas
d'ailleurs inéligible puisque s'il sort
surtout été suspendues à la paire étant
également une solution est une
composante de la peine comme la prison
je vous lis quelques commentaires des
internautes
nicole par luc à isaac aussi en disant
qu'il usa qui avaient aussi été
condamnés à la prison ferme et il a fait
zéro jours de prison comme vous le
rappeliez caroline eric une personne
normale aurait-elle été condamné
pareillement leur cas n'est pas unique
du tout et d'ailleurs la question selon
vous le verdict des balkany est il trop
sévère les internautes répondent à 66%
non il trouve que ce ver de la grappe
les dominos je suis allé sur les huit
heures là cet après-midi le déferlement
de haine à l'égard de patrick balkany
est un vrai semblables les gens disent
yes formidable le goût du sang dans la
bouche des français me paraît incroyable
ce qu'il y à aussi il ya eu il ya eu
tout un passif au tour de patrick
balkany et de son épouse il ya peut-être
eu énormément de fantasmer a eu aussi
quand même une condamnation qui est
lourde des faits qui sont précisément
exposé un enrichissement qui est massif
une vie dans le luxe qui est à l'expo à
l'exposition de tout le monde et je
pense qu'effectivement c'est ça qui peut
susciter chez les français ce rejet
massif non mais le fait de se réjouir de
la condamnation d'un homme moi me paraît
toujours assez étonnant et surtout non
pas de sa condamnation
mais du fait qu'il aille en prison et
les gens sont pas très graves et vous
pouvez voir en extérieur ça vous trouvez
que les français de richard décidément
compliquée fait pitié pitié que les
graver sur laquelle j'ai vu de suisse ça
vous paraît effectivement vrai que c'est
les français aiment le goût du 100m
s'acharner comme ça sur alors et le goût
du sang l'expression était forte mais
incontestablement il y a en ce moment
une on peut dire une haine qui visent à
vis des politiques
et effectivement patrick balkany était
une figure qui n'y figure qui
concentrait ça moi j'ai encore une fois
je voudrais peut être nuancer je pense
que il a pendant toute sa carrière il a
eu une forme d'oeuf l'ambiance est pas
la première fois qu'il est condamné
rappelons le quand même
il l'a été à la fin des années 90 déjà
ça lui avait valu d'ailleurs un
purgatoire politique pendant un certain
nombre d'années puis il était revenu
donc je crois que à un moment donné
quand on
il assumer ce côté flamboyant ce côté
encore une fois insolent et bien la
peine est lourde on peut l'attendre
plein discuter comme vous le faites les
français s'en réjouissent ceux qui s'en
réjouissent pourquoi en réalité pour une
raison simple c'est parce qu'il était
l'incarnation de deux figures only en
france c'est-à-dire l'élu la cote de
popularité des élus quand une très
mauvaise en ce moment d'une manière
générale et c'est le riche c'est celui
parce que dans le cadre at-il balkany ne
l'oublions pas il avait un patrimoine
familial
sa femme encore plus et c'est ce qu'ils
ont d'ailleurs mis en avant pendant le
procès en disant que cet argent n'était
pas de l'argent public
là c'est à voir que c'est pas clair du
tout mais que c'était de l'argent
familiales notamment je dois le dire
déposé en suisse dont vous voyez la
suisse est un peu coupable d'entravé
rossi